En la tabla que tenemos aquí tenemos dos
comunidades diferentes: Comunidad 1 y Comunidad 2,
cada una de ellas contiene tres especies
diferentes, vemos las poblaciones de esas
tres especies diferentes y también vemos
que el número total de individuos en cada
comunidad es el mismo, ambas tienen un total
de 1,000 individuos. Ahora, mi pregunta es,
sólo intuitivamente con base en los datos de esta
tabla, ¿cuál comunidad es más diversa y por qué,
la Comunidad 1 o la Comunidad 2? Muy bien, ahora
pensemos en esto juntos. Como ya lo mencionamos,
tienen el mismo número de individuos y podrían
estar pensando que la cantidad de especies podría
estar relacionada con la diversidad, y tendrían
razón: el número de especies contribuye a la
diversidad. Pero nos enfrentamos a una situación
en la que ambas comunidades tienen el mismo número
de especies, cada una tiene tres especies, pero
cuando miramos los datos es claro que la Comunidad
2 está formada principalmente por la especie A
y tenemos grupos muy pequeños de especies B y C,
mientras que la Comunidad 1 se distribuye más
uniformemente, de modo que intuitivamente parece
que la Comunidad 1 es más diversa. Pero esto
sólo fue mi intuición o nuestra intuición, y los
números aquí son bastante claros: la distribución
de las especies es más uniforme aquí y aquí tiene
mucho peso en la especie A. Pero puede que no
siempre sea tan claro, por lo que sería útil
tener algún tipo de forma cuantitativa para medir
la diversidad de una comunidad. Y afortunadamente
para nosotros hay una forma cuantitativa de
hacerlo, llamada Índice de diversidad de Simpson,
y la forma en que se calcula es igual a 1 - Σ.
Para cada especie tomamos el número de individuos
de esa especie dividido entre el tamaño de la
comunidad al cuadrado, así que para cada una de
las comunidades hacemos este cálculo, lo elevamos
al cuadrado y luego lo sumamos para cada una de
estas especies. Así que calculemos el Índice
de diversidad de Simpson para las comunidades
1 y 2. Les animo a pausar el video y a trabajar
en esto por su cuenta antes de trabajar juntos.
Comencemos con la Comunidad 1, así que el
Índice de diversidad para la Comunidad 1,
lo pondré entre paréntesis, va a ser igual a
1 menos... Tenemos (325 / 1,000)². Recuerden,
vamos a sumar cada una de estas especies: más
305, (305 /1000)² + (370 / 1000)². Necesito
cerrar mis paréntesis y podemos simplificar esto
un poco. Esto es igual a 1 menos, il al cuadrado
es un millón, entonces todo esto será sobre
1 millón, y vamos a tener 325² + 305² + 370²,
y eso nos va a dar 325² + 305² + 370² es igual
a eso. Ese es el numerador que tenemos aquí,
y lo voy a dividir entre 1 millón: dividido entre
un millón: 1, 1, 2, 3, 1, 2, 3. Esto es un millón,
es igual a esto, y luego voy a restar eso de
1, así que pongamos un signo negativo aquí y
digamos más 1 es igual a 0.664, de modo que esto
es aproximadamente igual a 0.664. Ahora hagamos
lo mismo con la Comunidad 2. Si lo escribo aquí,
el Índice de diversidad para la Comunidad 2 es
igual a 1 menos, pongo un gran paréntesis
aquí, y vamos a tener (925 / 1000)² + (40 /
1000)² + (35 / 1000)². Si simplificamos de manera
similar, esto es igual a 1 menos todos estos
miles al cuadrado que es igual a 1 millón y es un
denominador común. Vamos a tener 925² + 40² + 35²,
y luego esto va a ser aproximadamente igual a 925²
+ 40² + 35² es igual a esto, y lo dividimos entre
1 millón. Así que dividido entre 1,1, 2, 3, 1, 2,
3, sí, seis ceros es igual a eso. Y luego a 1 le
resto esto y obtienes que es aproximadamente igual
a 0.142. Cuando usamos el Índice de diversidad de
Simpson, vemos muy claramente que concuerda con
nuestra intuición: la Comunidad 2 tiene un Índice
de diversidad más bajo que el de la Comunidad 1,
y es consistente con nuestra intuición de que es
menos diverso. Los ánimo después de este video a
que piensen por qué esto tiene sentido matemático.